alors justement on a Chami avec nous ce
soir Chami est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer vous vous êtes arrivé après
iromi c'est ça alors moi j'ai été
contacté le le 4 juillet de cette année
pour justement au début je savais pas
trop ce que c'était on m'avait pas trop
expliqué mais une mission qui devait
débuter le lendemain donc le 5 juillet
d'accord euh donc j'ai dit pourquoi pas
j'étais disponible à cette période donc
j'ai dit pourquoi pas c'était pour 5
jours environ ensuite donc j'ai eu le
coup de fil de Delon d'accord c'était
quoi la mission c'était une protection
de personne de d'Alain Delon au début je
ne savais pas que c'était Alain Delon
d'cord d'accord vous avez euanouka c'est
ça après j'ai donc quand j'ai accepté
j'ai eu donc une dame qui m'a appelé
elle s'est présenté donc c'était Anouka
Deon et c'est là qu'elle m'a dit que
c'était pour éventuellement la la
protection de son
papa dans sa résidence à douchi d'accord
alors donc là vous vous avez travaillé
donc vous arrivez c'est Anouka qui qui
fait qui qui vous reçoit comment ça se
passe c'est ça c'est Anouka qui me
reçoit bon moi je suis arrivé le 5
juillet d'accord je sais pas si c'est
une date qui vous parle ou pas mais le 5
juillet euh ils ont remercié ils ont
remercié la fameuse c'est ça gouvernante
ils ont ils ont remercié donc ils ont
renvoyé et remis donc la gouvernante qui
se disait être la la compagne absolument
ilst mis les affaires sur le trottoir
d'accord ouais c'est ça l'histoire ouais
ah oui c'est exactement l'histoire la
famille c'est après je vous avais pas vu
Mo j'étais pas sur place ah super super
non et donc qu non en fait les affaires
ils ont été mis sur le trottoir bien
après hein c'était pas le le 5 juillet
ça a été bien après et ça a été sur euh
euhaprès que les enfants ont avisé leur
conseil d'accord donc le 5 juillet les
affaires d'irom Rollin n'étaient pas du
tout sur le trottoir je vous rassure
j'étais là d'accord d'accord donc euh
donc vous arrivez donc moi je suis
arrivé homir Rolin bon il y a eu
l'histoire quiil y a eu
euh que vous connaissez maintenant un
petit peu donc on voilà on a voilà on a
demandé à y renir Rin de de le papa ne
voulait plus qu'elle reste dans dans sa
propriété d'accord donc voilà comme l'a
dit Monsieur on l'aacompagné et cetera
d'accord alors donc vous c'était quoi
votre mission donc ma première mission
moi c'était faire en sorte parce que
romolin le 5 juillet n'était plus dans
dans la propriété elle était partie en
course ou je ne sais guerre bref et
c'était de faire en sorte que cette dame
ne remett plus les pieds dans la
résidence de monsieur d'accord c'est
incroyable donc vous vous étiez un peu
là pour dire si elle revient la
dehors pas la dehors puisquelle
était déjà dehors d'accord mais donc
qu'elle puisse qu'elle ne puisse plus
que pour l'instant que pour l'instant
monsieur Delon ne puisse plus enfin ne
veuille plus le qu'elle soit dans être
en contact qu'elle soit qu'elle soit
dans sa dans sa dans sa propriété
ouais c'est c'est fou euh non mais c'est
c'est fou he fou parce que si çaouve il
voulait qu'elle rentre on l'empêche de
rentrer alors alors donc non non il ve
donc voilà et donc vous avez travaillé
avec eux donc quoi juillet août
septembre octobre c'est ça jusqu'au 10
10 décembre de cette année j'ai été j'ai
été limogé par par les enfants d'accord
pour une raison alors c'est quoi
pourquoi vous avez été renvoyé bah en
fait la sécurité comment ça se passe
c'est même chez vous ici je pense que
vous avez des agents de sécurité devant
les portes il y a ce qu'on appelle un
carnet de bord plus communément aussi
une main courante donc voilà nous on
écrivait quand je dis nous c'est on
était deux voire trois agents de
sécurité à tourner dans dans la
résidence quand moi je promenais mes
weekends j'avais donc un relais et on
écrivait donc un carnet de bord une main
courante et on écrivait tout de de ce
qui se passait donc donc voilà et puis
là le 10 10 décembre 2023 j'ai un
collègue qui a pris ma relève Alain
Fabien l' gentiment il un petit peu
enfin voilà il il lui a demandé ce que
c'était et mon collègue lui dire oh ben
non c'est une main courante écoute on
écrit tout ce qui se passe à l'intérieur
alors justement c'est ça l'histoire il
paraî de ce que je sais je vous dis tout
chamid on m' dit c'est que vous vous
teniez et ça c'est ça qui est important
un carnet de bord dans lequel vous
parliez des cvic enfin des fait un peu à
à Alain Delon par par ses ses fils c'est
ce que c'est ce qu'on m'a dit est-ce que
c'est vrai ou pas c'est un carnet de
bord qui où il y avait tout et n'importe
quoi j'ai envie de dire c'estàd
l'infirmière qui pardon vous mettiez
quoi dans ce carnet ce qui peut nous
intéresser c'estàdire sur le traitement
d'Alain Delon par par ses fils ou par sa
fille il y avait quoi les comportements
que les enfants auraient pu avoir avec
avec le papa comme aussi je vous dis le
la chose la plus lambda la médecin qui
arrive à
17h55 est reparti à 18h30 voyez on
écrivait vraiment les entrées et les
sorties ou mais c'est ce carnet c'est ce
carnet de bord qui a fait que vous avez
été foutu dehors ça donc c'est qu'il y
avait des choses compromettantes dedans
bien sûr alors qu'est-ce qu'il y avait à
peu près enfin sans nous dire moi je
voilà je vais pas rentrer dans les
détails ce qu'il y avait je vous dis oui
effectivement il y avait des choses
compromettantes sur les enfants quels
enfants surtout surtout sur le plus
jeune alin Fabien alin Fabien qui quoi
quoi quoi par exemple non quelqu des
fois il avait un pour moi s'il était un
peu bline on va dire avec son papa c'est
c'est c'est c'est vague ouais je sais
c'est au niveau des au niveau du
vocabulaire au niveau de des gestes au
niveau de quoi ouais beaucoup au niveau
du vocabulaire les gestes ça a pas été
jusqu'à une menace physique d'accord
mais c'est vrai que voilà au niveau des
de la parole au niveau de de plein de
choses quel genre de choses au niveau du
vocabulaire quoi il parlait mal à à son
père quoi il s'agaçait il s'agaçait il
répondait à son
papa il s'agaçait beaucoup il s'agaçait
beaucoup ça vous le notiez sur le carnet
de bord ça je le notais vous disait quoi
aujourd'hui Alain fabien a traité son
père de telle chose ou telle chose c'est
ça voilà il a répondu à son père son
père je pense que une grande partie des
Français connaissent bien l'in Delon et
son caractèreou donc il suffisait que
Monsieur Delon lui dise une chose un peu
voilà qu'un papa serait susceptible de
dire à son fils un mécontentement tout
simplement et puis c'est vrai que Alan
Fabien aurait pu pouvait sortir de de s
euh et lui répondre d'une façon je
dirais pas jusqu'à agressive mais un peu
vous avez passé 5 mois euh nonstop avec
eux quasiment donc là donc vous vous
êtes quand même un témoin clé de
l'affaire de ce qui se dit puisque
aujourd'hui on se dit voilà d'un côté il
y a une partie des enfants qui disent
que au contraire que Anouchka profite de
l'état de son père pour abuser de lui et
de l'autre on dit que voilà que les les
les les les fils au contraire ont un
comportement limite avec leur père c'est
ça G c'est ça en fait ce que vous avez
noté c'est que le le plus jeune des
enfants manquait de respect à son père
régulièrement vous avez assisté à des
échanges c'est très ce sens j'ai assisté
à des échanges un peu muscl un peu
musclés si on veut musculature non pas
mais voilà c'estd en fait moi je suis là
pour ça justement je suis là pour ça
j'aurais pu être là parce que il y a des
choses qui ont été dites ces derniers
jours moi je alors c'est quoi justement
parce que ce qui ce qui dit sur Anouka
pour vous c'est c'est c'est n'importe
quoi
complètement et puis je trouve ça
dommage parce que moi je m'entendais
avec les trois enfants je vais pas dire
je suis mieux avec anuska ou avec alin
Fabien Antony je m'entendais avec les
trois enfants et peut-être encore
aujourd'hui bon là je pense que ils sont
pas spécialement courants donc peut-être
en vouloir mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que j'aurais pu être là pour
défendre entre guillemets les dire que
un autre enfant aurait pu dire sur
Antony mais là vous ce qui vous a gêné
c'est ce qui a été dit sur Anouka mais
oui complètement pourquoi parce que
dites-nous qu est Anouka c'est quoi
c'est c'est celle qui c'est celle qui
est plus la plus proche de son père elle
a déjà eu un comportement
elle voilà qui peut être un mauvais
comportement avec son père ou pas du
tout Anouka quand je vais voir quand je
vais voir alin h et que je lui dis que
sa fille arrive
ouais il est comme un fou comme fou
ouais c'est vraiment c'est ça il est
comme un fou il est là il demande à
l'infirmière de de de voilà de le
préparer et cetera limite de lui mettre
un petit coup de peigne vous voyez il
est comme un fou quand Anouka arrive ça
y est il faut voyez il demande à
l'infirmière pareilfin il demandeàand
vous entendez des c'est Anthony qui dit
qu'il va porter plainte qui a porté
plainte d'ailleurs contre
Anouchka est-ce que vous comprenez quand
ils disent que c'est quoi qu' qu'elle
abuse de son père de qu'elle met en
danger aussi leur père he qu'est-ce que
vous répondz à ça parce qu'elle veut
l'amener en Suisse ou c'est ça tout le
débat est là traitement pour un
traitement tout le débat est là alors
justement ça c'est important parce que
là vous êtes vraiment témoin quand même
cloui ah ben moi je suis là que pour
dire la vérité je suis pas là pour
enfter certain et monter les autres moi
je suis là pour dire la vérité parce que
ça fait quelques jours que je suis pas
très bien parce que je suis quand même
donc je me sentais un peu obligé de
venir et parler
anoska avait emmené son père en Suisse
pour une seule raison d'après ce que
j'ai vu et ce que j'ai entendu et je
pense que que c'est celle-là anuska
avait emmené son père parce que son père
il doit il doit faire des test il doit
faire des examens tous les deux voire 3
mois en Suisse chez des grands
professeurs d'après c'est dire et
d'après ce que j'ai vu et entendu donc
monsieur Delon doit aller en Suisse pour
justement continuer son checkup et
cetera et cetera les garçons sont contre
mais non tu comprends ici on a ce qu'il
faut h alors je vais me faire sûrement
lyncher plus tard mais il y a pas de
souci j'assume mais c'était un médecin
de campagne qui soignait Alain Delon on
n'est pas en train de parler de
quelqu'un qui n'aurait peut-être pas les
moyens de d'avoir des professeurs d'être
suivis c'est un médecin de campagne elle
est très gentille cette dame il n'y a
pas de souci mais franchement aucun
professeur n'est venu voir Monsieur
Delon depuis que je suis là-bas aucun le
seul médecin qui est venu c'est une
charmantee d'ame médecin de campagne
donc encore une fois c'est pour ça je me
dis je j'ai rien contre les médecins de
campagne loin de là bien au contraire
mais moi je pense que les les garçons là
ils sont complètement perdus sur cette
histoire là Anouka veut emmener son père
pour une seule bonne raison c'est ça
c'est pour les checkup et bien sûr
parallèlement à ça ben elle sera plus
proche de son père parce queka tout le
monde le sait habite Genève donc donc
elle aurait envie d'avoir son père à
côté d'elle et puis alin Delon il a
envie de la suivre en fait finalement
puce qu'il a il a tout son toute sa tête
et et s'il lui fait confiance pourquoi
je comprends pas même pas le le débat
alors justement il a toute sa tête ou
pas c'est ça bonne question
moi je suis pas médecin pour vous dire
il a toute sa tête par contre il vous
parlait vous répondiez exactement c'est
ce que j'allis en venir je suis pas
médecin pour vous dire il a toute sa
tête ou il l'a pas cependant ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que moi quasiment
toutes les après-midis et ben je buvais
le café avec Monsieur Delon j'ai
peut-être un privilège que j'ai pour
certains donc je vous le dis clairement
quasiment toutes les après-midis je
buvais un café avec Monsieur Deon je lui
donnais des enfin on mangeait ensemble
on se faisait un petit un 4 He il adore
ça et et voilà je parlais avec lui il me
raconta des histoires que à la Brûlerie
il m'a raconté l'histoire du château de
La Brûlerie donc c'est son domaine à
Douch non mais donc pour vous donc pour
vous il est il est pas dans un état
enfin il comprend qu' est conscient mais
carrément d'accord moi quand quand quand
j'entends il est fou il peut pas ceci il
peut pas
cela franchement je suis je suis
abassourdi parce que ce que j'entends et
c'est pour ça que je suis là aujourd'hui
même pour Monsieur Deon peut-être qu'il
va me dire de quoi tu te mailes toi il
va sûrement me le dire peut-être si je
le revois mais la vérité c'est pour lui
que je je suis là alors il y a eu un
enregistrement d'Alain Fabien qui a
apparemment enregistrer sa sœur aussi et
des discussions à s dépend exactement
alors moi l'enregistrement il dit pas
grandchose en fait c'est pas fou fou
désolé l'enregistrement je sais pas si
vous voulez on peut écouter une partie
de l'enregistrement mais vous allez nous
dire vous allez réagir Fabien et Chami
mais vous écoutter voilà il a enregistré
sa sœur à son insu lors d'un échange
avec son père
[Applaudissements]
écoutez je suis fatiguée papa
ouais je suis fatiguée je suis énervée
ce soir à cause de tout ce qui se
passe papa
oui bon on est en train de m'enterrer et
toi on est en train de te prendre pour
un débile
je sais
papa il faut que tu te méfies surtout un
débile
toi une fille qui manipule qui manipule
son père bah ouais mais papa il va
peut-être falloir dire un
truc parce que là tu le piège il va se
refermer sur toi là le alors voilà c'est
après la suite c'est pas ouf he vraiment
l'impression voilà c'est pas des
révélations incroyable qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez je pense que c'est c'est
franchement c'est complètement je sais
pas pourquoi il a fait ça là Fabien il a
voulu répondre à l'avocat de de Anouchka
qui qui a pris la parole sur BFM TV
dimanche à
18h45 et qui affirmait qu'il était
fatigué comme un homme de 88 89 ans mais
que il était parfaitement clair lucide
enfin et cetera qui avait aucun problème
il répondait pas aux questions vraiment
en même temps du journaliste mais mais
donc il a il a balancé ça à alin Fabien
pour montrer un petit peu que quand lui
fait répéter tro quatre fois le mot BFM
pour qu'il entende bien puiss s news et
cetacord c'est pour ça qu'il a balancé
ça il a balancé ça parce que c'est une
réponse à l'avocat qui qui qui voilà qui
défendait à juste titre d' parce que
c'est vrai que ce que vous nous avez dit
à un instant donc Alain Delon il
comprend tout à fait ce qu'on lui dit il
comprend la guerre entre ses enfants là
il comprenit Alain Delon il comprend
tout de ce qu'on lui dit d'accord là ce
qui a été ça c'est important rig c'est
un scoop
le procureur s'interroge derre procure à
la rigueur ce qu'on pourrait euh ce
qu'on pourrait reprocher et c'est même
pas un reproche quand je vais vous le
dire même vous ça va peut-être vous
faire sourire c'est qu'il entend mal à
88 ans on a des problèmes de diion
Monsieur Delon Alain il est vous le
connaissez encore une fois il a son
caractère il veut pas mettre ses sonoton
on se bat tous les jours quand je dis on
c'est l'infirmière et même moi des fois
m'appelle elle me dit chamis s'il te
plaît tu peux me donner un coup de main
et tout il veut pas il veut pas mettre
ses sonoton moi quand je parle avec lui
je me mets à côté de lui je prends une
chaise je m'installe à côté de lui et on
discute et je lui parle dans l'oreille
pour qu'il entende voilà oui c'est vrai
que et puis à cause de d'une d'une de
ses maladies il il a un petit peu la
gorge aussi moi moi au début il parlait
très bien il me criait dessus ça c'était
très bien aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'il a
il la voix un peu on dirait que comme si
qu'il avait un rume un peu enroué mais
d'après la médecin c'était à cause de
cette maladie il comprend l'Ance que
vous disz c'est que il comprend ce qu'on
ce qu'on lui vous avez une dernière
question pr mais est-ce que réellement
il comprend par exemple que ses deux
fils sont en train de vouloir là le
spolier ou d'être contre sa fille ça
doit lui faire mal que les deux fils
soient contre Anouchka mais complètement
complètement complètement encore une
fois moi quand je vous dis Anouka arrive
quand je lu dis que oui Anouka arrive il
est il est heureux et quand je lui parle
de certains autres enfants qui arrivent
ah ouais il est malheureux lesquel
lesquels après il en a pas
50ous ouais c'est vrai sur jeis juste
vous dire quelque chose par que vous
avez dit qu chose oui après le bisou fou
j' dire quelque chose ma belle-mère tin
est en Suisse je vais vous dire quelque
chose vous avez vous avez dit quelque
chose qui est très juste que la médecine
en Suisse
est redoutable est incroyable plus que
parce que je vais vous dire quelque
chose ma belle-mère qui était qui avait
un peu perdu la tête qui a eu un rein en
moins a été transféré en Suisse parce
que les soins sont intensifs et les
Suisses au Allemagne Suisse allemande
sont beaucoup plus fort que les soins
français effectivement pour assister les
gens qui sont
écoutez son mal la Suisse estès très
très
trèsère qui son ance très rapide c'est
qu'en fait on reproche aussi de choses
qu'on reproch
cétait le fait d'emmener son père en
Suisse deuxième d'être pas assez
présente moi je peux vous dire que tout
le temps que j'étais là Anushka au début
elle venait énormément de temps et là
faut pas oublier une chose c'est qu'
anuska c'est une mère de famille elle a
un gosse de 3 ans et demi en Suisse
qu'elle ne peut pas tout le temps tout
le temps être là mais elle est là au
maximum de du temps c'est vrai que je
l'ai vu très souvent douchci merci merci
merci à tous merci Fabien tu reviendras
à nous voir parce que cette affaire elle
va rebondir merci à tous tout de suite
c'est maagéon sur V merci
à